I've done a bunch of videos already on
respiration and I think even before
those videos you had a sense that we
need oxygen that we need oxygen and that
we release co2 and if you watched the
videos on respiration you know that we
need the oxygen in order to metabolize
our food in order to turn our food into
ATP's that can then drive other types of
cellular functions or anything that we
have to do move or breathe or think or
everything that we have to do and that
through the process of respiration we
break down those sugars and we release
carbon dioxide so in this video what I
want to do is kind of take a big step
back and think about how we actually get
our oxygen into our body and how we
release it back out into the atmosphere
or another way to think about is how we
ventilate ourselves ventilation how do
we get the oxygen in and how do we get
the carbon dioxide out and I think any
of us could at least start off this
video it starts off and either our nose
or our mouth I always have a a clogged
sinus so I often have to deal with my
mouth I sleep with my mouth open often
but always starts in our nose or our
mouths let me draw someone with the nose
and a mouth so let's say that this is my
person maybe his his mouth will be open
so that he can breathe so this is let me
his eyes aren't important but just so
that you know it's a person so this is
my test subject or the person I'm going
to use to diagram that's his ear maybe
he has maybe he has a bit of a I mean
just give him some hair oh maybe some
side where anyway I'm most - all of that
is irrelevant but this is our guy this
is the guy that's going to show us how
we take air in and how we take air out
of the body so let's go inside of this
guy and we like to draw his outside
first now let me see how well I can do
this so this is outside the guy that I
look great so let's say the guy looks
something like this and then you know
he's got this is his shoulders just like
that that's our guy
all right so in our mouth we have our
oral cavity right there which is just
the space that our mouth creates we have
our oral cavity I could draw our tongue
in all of that and maybe I will maybe
I'll draw our the tongue you know maybe
the tongue looks something like that but
you have this space inside of the mouth
call that the oral cavity so this space
inside of our mouth just like that this
is the oral cavity oral cavity oral for
mouth cavity for space or hole or
opening and then also you have your
nostrils and they open up into a nasal
cavity so they open up into a nasal
cavity so that's another big space just
like this and we know that they connect
they connect at the back of our nose or
the back of our mouth and this passage
right here this passage right here where
they connect is called the pharynx this
is the pharynx and that's you know when
your air goes through your nose
they say breathing through your nose is
better probably because it is and it
gets warmed up and and whatnot but you
can breathe through their side the air
goes in through either your nasal cavity
or your oral cavity and then comes back
through your pharynx and then it's the
flat pharynx splits into two pipes one
for well one air can go down either one
but the other one is for food so your
pharynx gets split in the back you have
your esophagus in the back and we'll
talk more about the esophagus in a
future video in the back you have your
esophagus and in the front let me draw a
little dividing line there in the front
maybe this is let me make it connect
like that actually maybe I do actually I
was using yellow I'm going to use yellow
to continue and I'm gonna use green for
the air so it divides just like that so
this is the dividing line so in the back
or the back of your you know behind your
air pipe you have your esophagus you
have your esophagus let me make that in
another color
so this right here is your esophagus
esophagus and then right here is your
larynx this is your larynx and I'm going
to concern ourselves with the larynx
esophagus is where your food goes down
we know that we eat food with our mouth
as well so this is where we want our
food to go down the esophagus
that's for food but the focus of this
video is our ventilation what do we do
with our air so I'm going to focus as
the air goes through our larynx our
larynx and the larynx is also our voice
box so as you hear me talking right now
they're these these little things right
about here that are vibrating at just
the right frequencies and I'm able to
shape the sound with my mouth to make
this video so that's also your voice box
but I won't focus on that right now it's
called a voice box because this whole
anatomical structure that looks
something like that
but then after the air passes through
the larynx this is on the way in it goes
to the trachea so then the air goes into
the trachea just like that which is a
essentially just the pipe for air the
esophagus is the pipe for food let me
write this down right here so this right
here is our trachea and then from the
trachea the trachea is actually a
reasonably rigid structure it has
cartilage around it and it makes sense
that it has cartilage you you don't want
you can imagine like a hose if it bent a
lot you wouldn't be able to get a lot of
water through it or a lot of air through
it so you don't want this thing to bend
a lot so that's why it nice to have some
rigidity so that's why it has cartilage
around it and then it splits it splits
into two tubes and I think you know
where these two tubes are going to and
I'm not drawing this in super detail I
just want you to get the idea of them
but these two tubes are the bronchi or
each one is a bronchus let me see these
are the bronchi these are the bronchi
and they also have cartilage so they're
fairly rigid but the bronchi keep
splitting they keep splitting into
smaller and smaller tubes just like that
at some point they stopped having
cartilage so they stopped being
reasonably rigid but they keep splitting
off
so I'll just draw them as these little
lines at some point they become such
thin things they just keep splitting off
so the the air just gets keep splitting
off and spread and goes down to the
different paths and when the bronchi no
longer have cartilage around them
they're no longer rigid the first of
those are called or actually all the
tubes after that point are called
bronchioles
these are bronchioles so for example
that we could call a bronchial and I you
know there's nothing fancy here it's
just a pipe that just gets thinner and
thinner and thinner we've labeled the
different parts of the pipes different
things but the idea is let's take it
through our mouth or our nose and we
just keep dividing and keep dividing
this main division into two different
paths that takes us into each of our
lungs so let me draw the sky's lungs
here so the lungs so that's one of this
guys lungs that's the other of this
guy's lungs and these bronchi or the
bronchi split into the lungs the
bronchioles are in the lungs and
eventually the bronchioles terminate and
this is where it gets interesting or
they keep dividing smaller and smaller
thinner and thinner thinner into these
little air sacs these little air sacs
just like that at the end of every super
small bronchial are these little air
sacs super small air sacs I'm going to
talk about these air sacs in a second
and these are called alveoli alveoli so
I've used a lot of fancy words but the
general idea is simple air comes into a
pipe the pipe gets thinner and thinner
and thinner and they end up at these
little air sacs and you're saying well
you know what how does that get the
oxygen into my system well the key here
is that these air sacs are super small
and have very very very thin walls or I
guess thin membrane so let me zoom in so
if I were to zoom in on one of these
alveoli and just to give you an idea
these are SuperDuper duper small I've
drawn them fairly large here but each
Alibi alveoli let me draw a little bit
bigger so let me draw these air sacs so
you have these air sacs like this
these air sacs and then you have a
bronchial that's terminating in that air
sac maybe a bronchial is terminating in
another air sac just like that another
set of air sacs just like that each of
these are only two to three hundred
microns in diameter so that distance
right there switch colors that's
distance right there is 200 to 300
microns and if in case you don't know
what a micron is a micron is a millionth
of a meter or you can view it as a
thousandth of a millimeter so this is
200 thousandths of a millimeter or you
can think of them as and this is
actually a very easy way to visualize it
this is about 1/5 of a millimeter of a
millimeter so if I actually try to draw
on the screen if you made this
fullscreen a millimeter is about that
far maybe a little farther than that
maybe about that far
so imagine 1/5 of that and that's how
what we're talking about the diameter of
one of these things and just to put it
in the whole scheme relative to cells
the average cell in the human body is
about 10 microns so this is only about
20 or 30 cells in diameter or relative
to the average cell in the human body so
these have a super thin membrane these
have a super thin membrane around so
this this you know if you view them as
balloons the balloon is very thin pretty
much one cell thick and they're
connected to the blood Sulli a better
way to think about is that our
circulatory system passes right next to
each of these things so you have blood
vessels that come from the heart that
come from the heart and they want to be
oxygenated and in general we want things
that the blood vessels that don't have
oxygen and I'm going to do this in a lot
more detail when I make the videos about
the heart and our circulation system
with the blood vessels that don't have
oxygen deoxygenated blood is a little
bit darker looks a little bit purplish
so I'll draw it as blue so this is these
are vessels that are coming from the
heart so this is blue so that this this
blood right here has no oxygen in it or
it's been deoxygenated or it's very
little oxygen in it and the word for the
blood
schools that come from the heart our
arteries let me write that down I'll
review that again when we go covered in
the heart
so arteries arteries are vessels are
vessels blood vessels from the heart
from the heart and you've probably heard
of arteries and vessels that go to the
heart are called veins veins go to the
heart and this is really important to
keep in mind because later on you're
going to see that the arteries don't
always carry oxygen or they're always
not deoxygenated and veins always aren't
one way or the other we're going to go
into a lot more detail when we actually
cover the heart and the circulatory
system
but just remember arteries go away veins
go to the heart so here these are
arteries these are arteries going away
from the heart to the lungs to the
alveoli because they want they want the
blood that's traveling in them to get
oxygen so what's going to happen is that
the air the oxygen is flowing through
the bronchioles I need to get new colors
is flowing through the bronchioles and
circulating around the alveoli filling
the alveoli and as they fill the alveoli
the little molecules of oxygen the
little molecules of oxygen are allowed
to across the membrane of the alveoli
and essentially be absorbed into the
blood and I'll do a lot more on that
when we talk about hemoglobin and red
blood cells we just have to realize that
there's just a lot of of capillaries
capillaries are just super small blood
vessels that allow air to pass
essentially oxygen and carbon dioxide
molecules to pass between them these
have a lot of capillaries on them that
allow the get the the exchange of gases
so the oxygen can go into this blood and
so once the oxygen so this is the vessel
that's coming from the heart and then
it's just a tube so then once it gets
the oxygen it's going to go back to the
heart so once again once it gets the
oxygen it'll go back to the heart once
it gets the oxygen goes back to the
heart and so essentially this is the
point where this vessel this pipe part
of our circulatory system goes from
being an artery because
from the heart to a vein because going
back to the heart and there's a special
word for these arteries and veins
they're called pulmonary arteries and
veins so this is a going away from the
heart to the lungs to the alveoli these
are the pulmonary pulmonary arteries and
going back to the heart are the
pulmonary veins pulmonary veins now
you're saying Sal what does pulmonary
mean well pulmo comes from the Latin for
of the lungs it literally means the
arteries that are of the lungs or that
go to the lungs and the veins that come
from the lung so anytime people talk
about pulmonary anything they're talking
about our lungs they're talking about
their or maybe something related to how
we breathe so it's a it's a good word to
know so anyway you have your oxygen
coming in through your your let me go
back to this guy I drew through your
mouth through your nose through the
pharynx they you know it could fill your
stomach we can blow up our stomach like
a balloon but that doesn't help us
actually get oxygen into our bloodstream
but that they the oxygen will come
through our larynx it into our tract
here through the bronchi eventually in
bronchioles ending up in alveoli and
being able to be absorbed into what were
the arteries but then we're going to go
back and then essentially oxygenate the
blood the the red blood cells become red
what's the hemoglobin has or actually
more specifically the hemoglobin becomes
very red or scarlet once it actually has
the oxygen and then we go back but at
the same time this isn't just about
getting oxygen into our arteries or int
onto the haemoglobin it's also about
releasing carbon dioxide so these these
blue arteries coming from the lungs are
also going to release carbon dioxide
into the alveoli and these will be
exhaled so we have oxygen coming in so
we have Oh two coming in when we inhale
other things will be coming in but the
o2 is what gets absorbed in the alveoli
and then when we breathe out when we
breathe out we're going to have carbon
that was in our blood but then it gets
absorbed into the alveoli and they get
squeezed out I'm going to tell you in a
second how it gets squeezed and then it
gets squeezed back out Co the carbon
dioxide it's actually that's squeezing
out that actually when the air goes back
out it can vibrate my vocal cords and
it'll allow me to talk but I'm not going
to go into too much detail of that so
the last thing to consider about this
whole pulmonary system or about our
lungs is is well you know how does it
how does it force the air in and how
does it force the air out and the way
it's done is really kind of like a like
a a you could imagine it is kind of a
pump or a balloon is that we have this
huge layer flat muscles let me pick a
good color here so if these are my lungs
I have a huge layer flat muscles right
here right here we color it in right
below the lungs and this is called a
thoracic diaphragm thoracic thoracic
diaphragm diaphragm and so when it's
relaxed it kind of has this arch shaped
and so the lungs are kind of squeezed in
they don't have a lot of volume but when
I essentially breathe in what's
happening is this thoracic diaphragm is
contracted and what's contracted it gets
shorter but more importantly it opens up
it opens up the space in where my lungs
are and so my lungs can fill up that
space so what it does is it essentially
you can imagine it's like pulling a
balloon larger making the volume of my
lungs larger and when you make the
volume of something larger so the lungs
will become larger as my thoracic
diaphragm is contracted and it kind of
arches down creates more space and as
the volume of something becomes larger
the pressure inside of them goes down if
you remember from physics the pressure
times volume is a constant so your
volume let me write this down
so when we breathe in breathe in our
brain is essentially telling our
diaphragm to contract so diaphragm
contracts we have more space around our
lungs our lungs expand lungs expand to
fill the space we have less pressure
here than we have outside we already can
view this negative pressure so air
always wants to go from high pressure to
low pressure so air is going to flow
into our lungs and hopefully there will
be some oxygen there that can then
essentially go into our alveoli and then
end up in our arteries and then go back
in the veins is oxygen attached to
hemoglobin I'll talk more about that in
detail and then when we stop contracting
the diaphragm it goes back to this
arched position it contracts it's kind
of like a rubber band it contracts back
the lungs and it essentially expels the
air back and now that air is going to
have a lot more carbon dioxide and just
to give a sense of you know our lungs
you know I can look at my lung I can't
look at them but they don't seem too
large you know how do I get enough
oxygen in them and what the key is is
that because of this branching process
because of this branching process the
insert and the alveoli the inside
surface area of the lungs are actually
much larger than you could imagine
or actually then I could have imagined
had someone not told me so it actually
turns out I looked it up the internal
surface area of your alveoli so the the
total surface area that where the oxygen
can be absorbed in or the carbon dioxide
can be absorbed out from the blood it's
actually 75 square meters 75 that's
meters not feet square meters if you
think about it that's like a imagine
some type of a tarp or or a field that's
you know that's that's almost nine by
nine nine meters by nine meters that's
almost 20 maybe 27 20 you know roughly
27 by 27 square feet that's the size of
some people's backyards that's how much
surface area you have inside of your
lungs it's all folded up that's how it
you know gets jammed into what looked
like relatively small lungs but that's
what gives us enough surface area for
enough of the air enough of the oxygen
to cross the alveoli membrane into our
blood system
enough of the carbon dioxide to go back
in and just to have a sense of
how many alveoli we had I still told you
that they're very small
we actually have 300 million in each
lung in each lung we have 300 million
alveoli so anyway hopefully that gives
you a decent sense of how we at least
get air or oxygen into our blood system
and carbon dioxide out of it in the next
video I'll talk more about our actual
circulatory system and how we get how we
get the blood how we get the oxygen from
the lungs to the rest of the body and
how do we get the carbon dioxide from
the rest of the body into the lungs